stop wasting your life
do you know how many people come to the
end of their lives wishing they could go
back and do it all over
don't be one of them there's an old
saying that says if you made your bed
you must lie in it
most people complain about their lives
not realizing that they themselves are
responsible for it you have to
understand that the decisions you make
today will determine who you are
tomorrow and what you will accomplish in
life but when people are full of pride
selfishness they say stupid things like
oh it's fine let me be lazy just today
let me do nothing let me stay in my
comfort zone a little longer let me just
expect to get everything for free let me
just waste my life
no it is time to examine yourself it is
time for self-awareness to ask yourself
the right kind of questions
like what is your purpose here on earth
why are you here
where does your soul come from and where
will it go when you die
are you wasting time on things that
won't even matter in the long run
are you a man of integrity a stand-up
guy
a man of honor do people respect you do
you keep your word
where are you going to be in 10 years
from now if you keep living the way you
do
and how do other people see you
do you ask yourself these types of
questions if not
why not
these questions are part of
self-awareness and if you don't know
yourself you got a problem because then
you will never change
most people waste their lives because of
comfort that gets stuck in life because
of the comfort zones comfort is the
enemy of growth and that is why you need
to get out of your comfort zone it is
not comfortable to wake up early in the
morning and go to gym when you are tired
it is not comfortable to work over hours
to get that promotion it is not
comfortable taking care of other people
while you might need the most care
it is not comfortable doing what must be
done even if you don't feel like it it
is not comfortable to get outside of
your comfort zone but that is the only
place where true growth will take place
so it's not always going to be easy it's
not going to be fun it's not going to be
comfortable to grow physically mentally
spiritually but
that is the only way to have a purpose
driven life
don't fear the uncomfortable fear feared
comfortable because it is there where
you get stuck in life and where you have
no purpose
too many people in the world are wasting
their lives some of you are wasting your
lives you might be breathing but you
might not be really living life
did you know
that there are 150 000 people
who are dying each and every day
death is certain your date uncertain
just look at how quickly the war broke
out in ukraine
thousands of people dying and even more
fleeing for their lives and leaving so
much uncertainty across the globe it is
time that you change the way you look at
life do you take your life for granted
do you take your family for granted do
you take your safe home for granted are
you just a sheep following sheep human
being
or are you actually standing up for what
is right in this world
or are you part of the problem are you
standing against the evil that is in the
world and those who want to implement
evil
not caring about the lives they destroy
listen to me today especially if you're
still young you need to ask yourself
these types of questions
and you need to ask the right kind of
questions to those who want to mislead
you those who want to control you and
just who want you to blindly believe
whatever they are saying like the mass
media you need to make decisions for
yourself because this is your life and
you need to make a decision do you want
to live in truth or in a made-up world
controlled by power-hungry people
a meaningful life can only be found in
truth because it is only the truth that
can set people free that can give you
real
freedom
but
how can you do it
if you don't know the truth of life
a lot of people wrongly believe that
they can find the answers within
themselves
you are just one small little puzzle
piece and you cannot see the full puzzle
by just looking at yourself you need to
look at all the puzzle pieces outside of
yourself but then you also need to look
at the creator of the puzzle piece to
understand the purpose and future of the
puzzle that we call
life a wise old woman once said if you
look at the world you'll be distressed
if you look within you'll be depressed
but if you look at god you'll be at rest
you know let's be brutally honest most
of us most of you
who are watching this video
won't even reach 60 years
and what would you have achieved by then
i hope for you a lot not in self gain
but in bringing value to other people
because what is the point if you gain
the whole world
and then you just die and you lose your
soul you are not taking anything with
you when you die
you can't make it into this world just
for a time a blink of an eye and you
will go out of it naked you see this
world is not our home it's just a
temporary place we're not gonna be here
soon all of us
are passing through
just look at all the generations who
live before us last time i checked they
are still dead
but have you ever asked yourself where
did their souls go and where will you go
when your earthly body dies
you know
my oldest brother he died in his early
20s he didn't expect it
the same happened
to my other brother 18 he didn't expect
it either and the same might happen to
you
when you look at yourself in the mirror
do you believe you are just a mix of
random chemicals that just happen to mix
together by chance
meaning you have no purpose
no meaning
or do you believe there must be a god
that created everything
i believe in god 100
because i experienced him every single
day there are many reasons for this that
i explained in my other video i also
experienced demons when i was little yes
the spiritual realm is real you can
watch my testimony on my other channel
the spiritual world around you is real
and god himself is spirit he is not in
some statue made by human beings he is
much
much more than that he created
everything and he sustains everything is
it not strange that when we humans when
we talk about these deep truths these
serious truths then something inside of
you stirs
you might even feel a little bit
uncomfortable do you know why
because that is what your inner being
truly searches for true spiritual life
that can only be found in god himself
the most famous book thousands of years
old
says in acts 17 verse 24 the god who
made the world
being lord of heaven and earth
does not live in temples made by man
nor is he served by human hands as
though he needed anything since he
himself gives to all mankind
life and breath and everything and he
made from one man every nation of
mankind to live on all the face of the
earth having determined allotted periods
and the boundaries of their dwelling
place
that they should seek god and perhaps
feel their way toward him and find him
yet he is actually not far from each one
of us
for in him
we live and move and have our being
as even some of your own poets have said
for we are indeed
his offspring you might say daniel i
don't care about religion well that's
good i'm not talking about religion here
we human beings we make religions up i'm
talking about the truth of life and god
himself who is a god of love who is
spirit who is the truth and you can only
have a true relationship with him in
spirit and in truth i'm not talking
about religion and you know when i talk
about don't waste your life most people
think that i'm talking about just this
temporary world no
this world and the things of this world
it is passing away
and so are we
but the decisions that you make in this
temporary world will determine where you
will go next
this life is one big test it is your
test and you need to make a decision
do you want to know the truth
do you want purpose
real peace
true spiritual life
the answers are all found in the creator
himself who is waiting for you to reach
out to him i want you to understand my
heart here i'm being open
transparent i'm saying these things
because i actually really do care about
you and if you want to have purpose if
you want to know the truth
if you want to know if god exists then
please watch these videos here from my
other channel and i'll see you there
and before you go always remember
life is short so don't waste yours